samedi prochain les jeunes ont
rendez-vous avec le sport au Vélodrome
national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les coachs et
athlètes professionnels de la team Cisco
partenaire officiel des Jeux olympiques
de Paris 2024 accueilleront 200 jeunes
de 8 à 16 ans baptisé génération
champion le but est de faire découvrir
les sports olympiques et paralympique
pour en parler avec nous Laurent mazory
le vice-président délégué au sport pour
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors quels
sont les objectifs de ce programme le
ramazori est-ce que c'est de transmettre
les valeurs du sport alors c'est de
transmettre les valeurs du sport mais
c'est aussi de le faire découvrir parce
qu'on a un certain nombre de jeunes qui
n'ont de vision du sport que ce qu'ils
ont mieux scolaire voir avec nos amis de
l'UNSS qui travaillent essentiellement
le mercredi et pour autant on est
souvent éloigné de ce que sont de ce
qu'est la pratique du sport au quotidien
mais également la pratique du sport de
haut niveau on a l'impression que
c'était un petit peu loin que ce sont
des gens hors normes que les sportifs
c'est pas nous et en réalité on veut que
les que les enfants de 50 ans de
l'ensemble des Yvelines puissent se
rendre compte qu'en réalité c'est à leur
portée qu'en pratiquant un sport en
amateur on peut progresser on peut y
prendre beaucoup de plaisir on peut
évidemment sauvegarder sa santé mais on
peut aussi travailler sur des valeurs
qui vont au-delà de celle du sport et
que le sport porte les valeurs de
respect les valeurs de de
d'appréhension et de compréhension des
règles les valeurs de travail en commun
pour les sports collectifs les valeurs
également de savoir appliquer respecter
des horaires les valeurs de se respecter
déjà soi-même ça sont des valeurs que
porte le sport et que portent le sport
de haut niveau en terme d'exemplarité
mais en termes de pratique également au
quotidien et peut-être révéler de futurs
grands talents ah bah écoutez je
l'espère 50 individu on a déjà produit
beaucoup dans beaucoup de disciplines je
me porte au golf je pense à la boxe je
pense à nos para raclette puisque les
parallèles sur Saint-Quentin sont très
présents ils le sont fortement à la fois
dans la pratique de leur sport mais
d'ailleurs également sur le travail de
l'innovation qui découle de la pratique
du de tout ce qui est le parathlétisme
mais pas que je pense au tir à l'arc
vous savez nous aurons du nous aurons du
BMX nous ont un ensemble d'éléments qui
sont à la fois du sport et qui relèvent
de haute technologie dans la pratique
des usages et du matériel qu'on utilise
pour pouvoir progresser dans ses sports
seront sur le territoire de 50 ans en
Yvelines durant les Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 on revient un peu sur
Génération champion quel sera le
programme de l'après-midi globalement
avec ces 200 jeunes quels sont les
sports qui vont pouvoir découvrir alors
le programme je note je regardais note
parce qu'en fait il est tellement touffu
donc on a environ 4 heures d'activités
diverses et variées d'ailleurs essayez
encore de vous inscrire et peut-être
quelques places sur le site
vous pouvez aller sur le site de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce qui
challenge.fr skit challenge
g.cyronisation parfaite donc on a quatre
heures de pratique de ces différents
sports on a des grands athlètes qui sont
présents je pense à Vincent Luis qui est
athlète et qui a été médaillée aux Jeux
Olympiques de Tokyo récemment la djid
Doukouré qu'on ne présente plus qui est
du monde du 110 mètres exact donc eux
ils vont être là sur tout ce qui touche
à l'emblème à porter ces jeunes et puis
les épreuves c'est donc le BMX le tir à
l'arc le basket l'athlétisme et le
tennis fauteuil je tiens beaucoup au
tennis fauteuil parce que d'abord c'est
très dur et c'est un sport qui est très
spectaculaire et on ne peut pas avoir
d'a priori j'insiste beaucoup sur le
parachutisme parce que vous savez qu'on
accueillera aussi des épreuves sur notre
territoire pour les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 il faut que les
jeunes viennent le voir il faut pouvoir
s'y impliquer et on peut pratiquer ce
para fauteuil quand on est pas soi-même
atteint de handicap donc il faut le
savoir et là on se rend compte de
l'effort que ça représente et tout cela
sera bien entendu encadré par les
équipes de professionnels qui sont là
pour accueillir à la fois les jeunes
mais aussi leur famille bien sûr le
vélodrome est très grand et il
accueillera tout le monde sans aucune
difficulté et alors comment ça va se
passer ils vont se challenger dans des
ateliers oui oui alors on est sur le
même modèle que ce que l'on fait
j'allais dire quotidiennement en
Vélodrome contrepartie de cyclisme il y
a une phase de comp et d'appréhension de
chacun de ces sports on apprend les
règles et pratiques quand on ne les
connaît pas ou on arrive à maîtriser les
différents outils quand il y en a besoin
je pense au tir à l'art par exemple et
puis petit à petit au fil de la journée
on va commencer en individuel et en
collectif puis après il y aura des
petites compétitions
d'un très très bon niveau qui
permettront aux autres de s'affronter
dans un esprit sportif et alors on est à
moins maintenant de 5 choses 500 jours
des Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres échéances comme ça à
venir comme génération champion qui vont
arriver à 50 ans en Yvelines alors on a
la semaine olympique qui est un petit
peu notre point récurrent qui a lieu
début avril dans dans 15 jours
maintenant enfin trois semaines entre 15
jours et trois semaines c'est un
événement important parce que entre
autres sur 50 ans Yvelines nous
dévoilerons un certain nombre de choses
qui touchent à la communication et au
sentiment d'appartenance donc je ne
pourrai pas le faire ce soir parce que
il y a ce qu'on appelle en anglais The
Revel donc le moment on va révéler tout
cela et ça c'est le point très récurrent
on a la nationale golf 8 également qui
arrive pareil dans 5 semaines maintenant
et qui est un élément maintenant 50
noirs qui est récurrent où tous les les
passionnés de golf se retrouvent
amateurs comme professionnel avec une
importante commission de golf qui sera
greffée également là-dessus puis bien
sûr on a manière récurrente notre bonne
de France qui aura lieu cette année au
mois de septembre on est très heureux de
l'accueillir à nouveau avec là aussi je
pense à nouveau sponsor mais je laisse
la Fédération française nous en parler
et puis vous savez ce qui est plus
important que tout et que peut-être la
population voit le plus sont les travaux
je pense entre autres aux travaux de la
comédie d'Élancourt parce qu'il faut
également qu'on ait des lieux pour
accueillir nos champions et la
population on a cette chance à
Saint-Quentin d'avoir un golf qui est
déjà prêt à Vélodrome qui est déjà prêt
et un stade de BMX qui lui aussi est
prêt par contre on a des travaux sur la
colline d'élanco pour accueillir les
épreuves de VTT et ça c'est très visible
pour tout notre population en tout cas
le sport vit bien dans les Yvelines se
porte bien en tout cas
nulle part dans les Yvelines je parlais
du golf vous savez peut-être ou si vous
ne savez pas je vous la prendre le
territoire de golf le plus fort de
France ce sont les Yvelines puisque
c'est la divine que nous avons le plus
de terrain de golf on en a pas 78
mais on n'est pas loin et bien merci
beaucoup Laurent mazory pour toutes ces
précisions nous suivrons de près cet
après-midi au Vélodrome national je
rappelle les quelques informations
pratiques génération champion c'est ce
samedi 18 mars au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de 13h à 18h30
l'inscription est obligatoire sur le
site internet qui va s'afficher sur
votre écran
venez nombre